♪ ♪
>> Hannity: BERNIE SANDERS NOW
SEIZES THE STATUS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
HE RECENTLY PICKED UP THE
ENDORSEMENT OF NEW YORK CITY
MIRROR, I CALL HIM COMRADE
BILL de BLASIO.
HE JOINS US LIVE TONIGHT TO
DISCUSS SANDRA’S CAMPAIGN.
THE STATE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH US
THE LAST TIME AND SAY AT LEAST
HE HAD THE GUTS TO COME ON.
GOOD FOR YOU.
I MEAN THAT.
LET ME START WITH BLOOMBERG.
I WANT TO PLAY TO THESE
COMMENTS.
I KNOW YOU ARE AGAINST STOP AND
FRISK.
>> RIGHT.
>> Hannity: I WOULD ARGUE
HIGHER CONCENTRATION OF CRIME,
MORE POLICE RESOURCES.
IT’S ABOUT PEOPLE.
THAT’S NOT HOW HE DEFINED IT.
>>>> THEY ARE MALE MINORITIES.
IT’S TRUE IN NEW YORK.
IT’S TRUE IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
CITY.
AND THAT’S WHERE THE REAL CRIME
IS.
PEOPLE SAY, OH, MY, YOU ARE
ARRESTING KIDS FOR MARIJUANA.
THEY ARE ALL MINORITIES.
YES, THAT’S TRUE.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE PUT ALL THE COPS IN
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS.
>> Hannity: YOU FOLLOWED HIM.
IS NOT RACIST TO YOU?
>> COME SURE.
THANK YOU FOR PLAYING THAT FOR
YOUR MILLIONS OF VIEWERS,
BECAUSE NOW MORE PEOPLE CAN SEE
WHO HE REALLY IS.
THAT POLICY DIVIDED A COMMUNITY.
>> Hannity: I DON’T EVEN THINK
IT’S A POLICY.
HE IS SAYING ALL CRIME, ONLY
MINORITIES, ONLY ARRESTING
MINORITIES, BECAUSE THAT’S WHERE
ALL THE CRIME IS.
>> HE’S TOTALLY OUT OF TOUCH
WITH THE PEOPLE IN HIS OWN CITY
WHEN HE SAYS THAT.
IT’S DEROGATORY.
IT’S UNFAIR.
IT’S NOT TRUTHFUL.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT, WHAT
HAPPENED?
IT MADE IT HARD FOR THEM TO BE
ON THE SAME PAGE.
LOOK, IF YOU ARE STOPPED, YOU
ARE A LAW BITE OR YOUR WHOLE
LIFE.
YOU ARE A YOUNG PERSON.
YOU GET STOPPED.
>> Hannity: HE SAID THROW THEM
UP AGAINST THE WALL.
>> LOOK, WHAT IT DOES IS IT
TAKES AWAY ANY SENSE OF
SELF-ESTEEM.
PEOPLE CAME TO HIM, CLERGY,
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THEY SAID, PLEASE, IT ISN’T
WORKING.
IT’S HURTING US.
HE DISDAINED THEM.
LET>> Hannity: LET ME PLAY THIS,
NOW.
>> WE ENDED THAT POLICY AND FOR
SIX YEARS, CRIME HAS GONE DOWN.
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE GOTTEN
BETTER.
WE HAVE ADDED 2,000 OFFICERS.
>> Hannity: WE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR COPS BETTER.
>> AND WE DO.
GOTTEN PRETTY MUCH ALL OF THEM.
HE SAID, BLOOMBERG SAID, OH, IF
YOU DON’T YOU STOP AND FRISK,
YOU WON’T BE SAFE.
WE GOT RID OF IT.
WE GOT SAFER.
WE ARE NOW ABLE TO HAVE THAT
RESPECTFUL POSITIVE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNITY.
>> Hannity: LET ME PLAY, NOW,
EVERYONE HAS A HEALTH CARE PLAN.
BLOOMBERG HAS HIS OWN PLAN.
BASICALLY, THE DEATH PENALTY.
YOU HAVE OUTLIVED YOUR
USEFULNESS.
YOUR EXPECTED AGE YOU ARE GOING
TO LIVE, YOUR LIFE EXPECTANCY.
GO HOME AND DIE.
THAT’S HIS POLICY.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> AT THE RATE WE ARE GOING, NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE A PROBLEM, WE
SAY WHICH THINGS AND WE ARE
GOING TO DO AND WHICH THINGS WE
ARE NOT.
IF YOU SHOW UP WITH PROSTATE
CANCER AND YOU ARE 95 YEARS OLD,
WE SHOULD SAY GO, LIVE A LONG
LIFE.
THERE’S NO CURE.
IF YOU ARE YOUNG PERSON, WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Hannity: GO HOME AND DIE?
>> SHAWN, THAT’S WHAT WE CALL
BEDSIDE MANNER RIGHT THERE.
WE SAW IT IN THE TWO DEBATES.
THIS GUY HAS NO CONNECTION TO
PEOPLE.
LOOK, ONE OF THE THINGS YOU AND
I TALKED ABOUT COME WITH THAT
MILLIONS OF VIEWERS WHO ARE
WORKING AMERICANS, EVERYDAY
PEOPLE.
I WANT TO TALK TO THEM TOO
PAIRED WE SHOULD ALL BE TALKING
TO EACH OTHER.
BUT WHEN YOU WATCH
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG, HE’S GOT NO
CLUE WHAT EVERYDAY PEOPLE ARE
GOING THROUGH AND HE DOESN’T
CARE TO KNOW.
IF YOU TRY TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, WHAT WAS HAPPENING
TO EVERYDAY PEOPLE, ALL HE COULD
THINK ABOUT WAS THAT THE ELITE
HE COMES FROM, HOW DO YOU TALK
ABOUT HEALTH CARE?
WE’VE GOT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO NEED HEALTH CARE.
HOW DO WE GET IT TO THEM THE
RIGHT WAY?
HOW DO WE PLAN YOUR FUNERAL?
THAT WAS SHOCKING TO ME.
>> Hannity: WHAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS, AND THE
REASON I AM ASKING FIRST, YOU
ARE NOT SUPPORTING HIM.
YOU ARE SUPPORTING SANDERS.
I WILL SAY THIS ABOUT SANDERS.
AT LEAST HE BELIEVES THIS.
I MEAN, HE IS SINCERE.
THIS GUY SUPPORTED STOP AND
FRISK FOR 12 YEARS.
SEVEN YEARS WHEN YOU WERE
MIRROR.
AND THEN HE SAYS, OH, I’M
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS MAY NOT LIKE
THIS AND STARTS WITH THE
CROCODILE TEARS.
YOU AGREE THAT THAT IS PHONY.
>> WORKING PEOPLE GET THIS ABOUT
BERNIE.
IT’S VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH HIM, BUT
YOU DON’T DOUBT THAT WHAT HE IS
SAYING IS THE TRUTH.
MOST POLITICIANS BLUNTLY, YOU
HAVE TO WONDER IF YOU’RE GETTING
THE REAL THING OR NOT.
>> Hannity: MORE ABOUT
VENEZUELA?
WHAT ABOUT HIS PRAISE OF
VENEZUELA, CUBA AND THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION?
THEY KILLED MILLIONS IN THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION.
>> COLD WAR.
>> Hannity: HE WAS THERE.
A NATION THAT KILLED MILLIONS.
BECAUSE THAT’S A KEY POINT.
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE WAS THERE?
RONALD REAGAN.
>> Hannity: YOU, BUT HE WAS
ASHLEY TELLING THEM, AMONG OTHER
THINGS --
>> THEY DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE COLD WAR.
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
ARE GOING TO GET PEOPLE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE A DECENT JOB AND WE
RESENT WAGES.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THE MIDDLE-CLASS SURVIVES AND
DEALING WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
ALL THINGS WERE AMERICANS --
>> Hannity: BERNIE WANTS TO
GET RID OF OIL AND GAS.
HOW DO WE SURVIVE THE LIFEBLOOD
OF THE WORLD’S ECONOMY.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE
APPEAR LET ME JUST MAKE THE
POINT.
BERNIE SANDERS BELIEVES AND WHAT
HE’S TALKING ABOUT.
HE GIVES YOU AN INCREDIBLE CLEAR
PICTURE OF WHERE HE WANTS TO GO.
RONALD REAGAN, YOUR UNCLE HE
KNEW WHERE HE WANTED TO GO.
YOU KNOW IT WITH BERNIE SANDERS.
HE IS ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE.
THE ELITES ARE NOT ABOUT WORKING
PEOPLE.
HE IS.
>> Hannity: HERE’S THE PROBLEM
HERE HE’S GOING TO TAX PEOPLE BY
HIS OWN ADMISSION AND MAKE
$29,000 OR MORE.
THEY’RE GOING TO GET SLAPPED
WITH A 4% TAX INCREASE FOR
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
HE IS GOING TO HIGH AND CURRENT
DOMINIC INCOME EARNERS.
CAPITAL GAINS, HE’S GOING TO
RAISE.
HE WANTS A WEALTH TAX.
THE DEATH TAX, 77%.
OKAY, NEW YORK GETS ANOTHER,
WHAT, 10% CUSTOMER AND I THINK
YOU ARE SITTING AT 3%.
THEY TAX PEOPLE, THEY PAY THEIR
TAXES, THEN YOU TAKE ANOTHER
BITE OF THE APPLE WITH A WEALTH
TAX IF YOU ARE DUMB ENOUGH TO
SAVE MONEY.
THEN, WHEN YOU DIE, YOU’VE GOT
TO GIVE 90% OF YOUR WEALTH?
DON’T YOU THINK THAT IS
LEGALIZED STEALING?
>> NO.
>> Hannity: WE SHOULD JUST
HAND IT OVER TO YOU.
>> REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
INDEPENDENTS, TWO THINGS.
ONE, TOO MUCH MONEY IN POLITICS.
THEY ALL LIKE TO SEE THE BIG
MONEY OUT OF POLITICS.
TWO, THEY ALL THINK THE WEALTHY
ARE NOT PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE
IN TAXES.
NO ONE DOUBTS THAT
BERNIE SANDERS IS GOING TO MAKE
IT MORE FAIR.
>> Hannity: YOU GOT TO GIVE ME
A STRAIGHT ANSWER.
HOW MUCH OF EVERY DOLLAR AFTER
YOU PAY STATE, LOCAL, FEDERAL,
PROPERTY TAXES, SHOULD EVERYBODY
BE ALLOWED TO KEEP CUSTOMER
ANYBODY.
BECAUSE I’M NOT GOING TO GIVE A
SINGLE NUMBER.
>> WHY NOT?
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
VERY WEALTHY PEOPLE --
>> Hannity: THEY ARE EARNING
IT.
HOW DID THEY GET THAT?
>> IT’S TIME FOR PEOPLE --
>> Hannity: HOW MUCH DOES
EVERY AMERICAN --
CAN I KEEP 40% OF EVERY DOLLAR?
>> MOST REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
TAXES.
>> Hannity: YOU WANT TO
LEGALIZED STEALING AND YOU WANT
TO COMPENSATE IT AND GIVE IT
AWAY.
THINK I’VE GOT A PRODUCTION FOR
YOU.
A LOT OF YOUR VIEWERS HAVE A
CHOICE BETWEEN BIDEN, BLOOMBERG,
BERNIE SANDERS.
A LOT OF YOUR VIEWERS ARE LABOR
UNION MEMBERS.
TRUMP>> Hannity: TRUMP IS GOING
WIN MY PEERS BECAUSE
BERNIE SANDERS IS GOING TO WIN.
>> Hannity: DONALD DRAY TRUMP
REELECTED THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES